نعود بكم مباشره الى كلمه للمستشار
الالماني في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
نحن نكسب اعضاء جدد والاف
الروس دفعوا
ثمن خطوات بوتين بارواحهم
الاوكران يدافعون عن حريتهم
بكل بثمن باهر جدا ولكن بعزيمه نشهد لها
ونحن ندعمهم في ذلك بشكل شمولي ولا طالما
احتاج الامر
المانيا بمفردها
قدمت 12 مليون يورو لمساعده اوكرانيا
العام الماضي
واستهدف واستضفنا اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
وكذلك
قبلناهم في جامعاتنا
ووفرنا ايضا
سلاحا وسلعا لاوكرانيا اكثر من اي دوله في
القاره الاوروبيه لكن
هذه
وفقا لتوقعات الجميع فنحن
نتحمل المسؤوليات
بحجمي دولتنا وبالتالي نحن
اخترقنا الكثير من القواعد الاساسيه
لالمانيا لكننا كنا في السابق لا نقبل
تقديم السلاح لاي حرب في هذه المنطقه
لكننا
تغيرنا في غيرنا اسلوبنا في هذه المره قل
للجميع انها ليست
اسلحتنا التي تطيل الحرب العكس وهذا
ياخذني للنقطه التاليه كلما اسرى بوتين في
ادراكه انه لن يحقق اهدافه لامبرياليه
فكلما كانت فرص انهاء الحرب باسرع ما يمكن
بسحب القوات المحتله الروسيه
كما اشار الرئيس سيلنتكي فان
في اجتماعاتنا
اكد عليها نحن
اوروبا
وتحالف عبر الاطلس والمجتمع دولي متحدين
في تحقيق هذا الهدف وهذا يشمل
المحاسبه على جرائم الحرب وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه التي ارتكبها الروس في اوكرانيا
من الجيد ان
يتعاطى المؤتمر الامني بهذه القضيه بانه
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك سلام دائم دون عداله
ولابد ان نضمن ان
الحرب هذه لن تستمر يجب ان نبقى محافظين
على التوازن بتقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا وتجنب
اي تصعيد غير مقصود
وانا سعيد
وممتن بان الرئيس بايدن وكثير من الحلفاء
الاخرين يتفقون معنا في هذا الراي فبعد كل
شيء المسار الذي اتخذناه معا
في
كان طريق جديد وللمره الاولى في التاريخ
قوه نوويه تقوم بشن حرب على ارض اوروبيه
وهذه سابقه لا نعرف ماذا يمكن ان نفعل في
مثل هذا الوضع
اعتقد اننا لابد ان
نفكر مليا بالتبعات والنتائج وان تنسق مع
شركائنا وحلفائنا فهذه حرب في دول الجوار
وفي اوروبا وهي حرب خطيره وعلى الرغم من
كل الضغط لان نتخذ خطوات وهذه موجوده كما
تعلمت فان المساله الاساسيه هي توخي الحذر
والوحده دون المضي باجراءات احاديه الجانب
ولكن هذه الحرب استمرت لفتره طويله واي
قرار
حول
منصات اطلاق الصواريخ
وايضا
بطاريات الباتريوت وكذلك الدبابات سنواصل
تقديم هذا السلاح
من يستطيعون ان يقدموا مثل هذه
الاسلحه لابد ان يواصلوا فانا
شخصيا انادي بهذه المساله وسنقوم بذلك
مجددا هنا في ميونخ نحن
نجعل هذا القرار اسهل على شركائنا بتدريب
الجنود الاوكراني هنا في المانيا حول
النرجسيات وكذلك على سلاح الذي يقدم وارى
ان هذا مثالا على نوعيه القياده التي يمكن
ان يتوقعها الجميع من المانيا وانا اقدمها
شركائنا والاصدقاءنا وهذا ياخذني الى
الرساله الرابعه المانيا ملتزمه لان تفي
بالتزاماتها لامن اوروبا
وعلى اراضي حلفاء الناتو دون تراجع او
تهاون في السنوات السابقه
لم نكن لنتوقع ان يكون هناك
تحدث حول مساله المسؤوليات الامنيه وانا
اتحدث هنا امامكم لا يؤكد لكم اننا وفينا
بالتزاماتنا وقدمناها
من خلال تقديم البنى التحتيه في
الشمالي البلطيق وكذلك
المحافظه على بقاء 17 الف جندي بحاله تاهب
تم ومن اجل تحقيق هذه النتائج وغيرها في
المستقبل
فنحن نواصل العمل وقد اسسنا القواعد
بتقديم
ميزانيه 100 مليار يورو لقواتنا المسلحه
وبدعم
حزب المعارضه الكبير في بلادنا دعمونا في
هذه الخطوه وهذه القدرات مهمه وكذلك
طائرات المواجهه والسفن
والدبابات ستؤدي لزياده
الانفاق على الذخيره وتدريب
والمناورات العسكريه هذه الفرصه لاؤكد ما
قلناه في قبل اي كان بعد بدء بعد ايام من
بدايه الحرب فاننا سنواصل
انتاجنا على شكل دائم
[تصفيق]
الاستثمار هذا التمويل بشكل مجدي فلا بد
من وجود
قطه صناعه
صناعه سلاح قويه في اوروبا وفي المانيا
ولابد ان نتعاون
استراتيجيا عندما ياتي الامر
لسياسات التسلح
وبالتالي
مع فرنسا واسبانيا ولدينا ايضا ارض
تدريب على المواجهه مع فرنسا وكذلك
مثال على ذلك وهو مبادره
الاوروبيه التي اقترحتها
المنيار لتكون خطوات تجاهها اوروبا
متحده في الدفاع وفي التسلح كما تحدثت قبل
ايام في جامعه براغ وكذلك اتخاذ الاجراءات
من
الناحيه الجيو السياسيه لتكون اوروبا اقوى
في هذا وايضا كجزء من التحالف تحالف
النيتو
هذا هو هدف المقترح الاوروبي الذي
تحدثنا فيه انا والرئيس مكرون حول اتفاق
بين صربيا
وسنستفيد من هذه الفرصه من اجل
الاستقرار في
غربيل البلقان وفي انحاء اوروبا
فبال فالامد لا يمكن ان يحقق عبر القوه
العسكريه لكننا بحاجه الى عالم على العالم
الافتراضي والعالم
الرقمي
لمسانده الجانب العسكري وكذلك المجتمعات
الديمقراطيه من المهم جدا ان
تزداد قوتنا وهذا لن يحد يحقق
بان ندير ظهرنا للعالم بل
او ان نكافح العولمه لابد ان نكون جزء من
هذا العالم
بل نقلنا لكم مشاهدينا جانبا من كلمه في
مؤتمر الامن في ميونخ حيث شدد بان اوروبا
الان موحده اكثر من اي وقت مضى وبان بوتين
لن ينجح واوكرانيا ستنتصر فيه حربها وقال
بانهم يقدمون لاوكرانيا احدث الاسلحه
والذخائر وهم مستمرون في ذلك وان المانيا
لا تفضل المضيف في اجراءات نحاديه بشان
الحربي في اوكرانيا ويتجنبون وقوع حرب بين
روسيا والنيت بشكل مباشر